how do you do a systematic literature
research prepare the current state of
research develop the theoretic
background derive your research
hypotheses we'll go over that in this
video Let's Start what is the goal of
the literature research
the goal of the literature research is
to describe the current state of
research to develop the theoretical
background of the thesis and to derive
the research hypotheses
notes before you start your literature
research find out what is expected from
your University or your supervisor
how comprehensive does your literature
section need to be what databases are
important in your field how should you
present the literature research in your
thesis
it is important that your literature
search is not the result of random fines
but that you are as focused as possible
in your search
the best way is to go through the
following five steps find Search terms
query databases pyramid scheme search
review literature get literature
find Search terms once you have chosen
your topic and narrowed down your
research problem the first thing you
need is good keywords for this create a
list of possible keywords
query databases it's great if you can
find as many Journal articles and books
about your topic as possible these are
found in electronic form in literature
databases
pyramid scheme search besides doing your
own search there is another way you can
quickly get useful literature sources to
do this just look at the bibliographies
of other thesis or Journal articles in
your research area in this way you will
move forward faster and be in the right
area from the start however it is
important that you get an idea of the
literature sources yourself and do not
simply blindly copy them review
literature now you need to filter out
the useful sources from your results
list since you want to finish your
thesis at some point you obviously can't
read all sources so the best thing you
can do is simply get an overview of the
individual literature and then decide
which one is worth reading in more
detail for this you can for example read
the abstracts which are short summaries
get literature finally you need to get
the full texts of the selected sources
of course you can find most full texts
on the internet hopefully free of charge
and not behind a paywall
sometimes it is a requirement of the
university to present the systematic
literature research in the form of a
flowchart if you want to present your
literature search in a flowchart you can
do it as follows
identification at the top you note the
number of studies you found
cleaning then the number of studies you
took a look at for example red the
abstract rating now the status that you
have completely gone through and finally
the number of studies that you use in
your work and which therefore also
appear in your bibliography now we know
how a systematic literature review is
done and we can move on to discuss what
to include in the literature section
state of research theories hypotheses
let's start with the state of research
in the state of research section you
summarize the most important research
findings from the literature on your
topic in doing so you should address the
following points how has research
changed in recent years what is the
current state of research what is the
direction of research right now and how
does your work fit into the state of
research you can present the state of
research either thematically or
chronologically if you proceed
thematically you saw the studies
according to their contents if you
proceed chronologically you saw the
studies by the year of publication
the second part of the literature review
is to find the needed series that you
will refer to in your quantitative
thesis
you should select one or more scientific
theories that are appropriate to your
research topic but what are theories in
quantitative research you examine a
small section of reality although it is
only a small section of reality this
small section is usually very complex
therefore an attempt is made to
establish statements or theories that
are free of contradictions
so reality is very complex therefore
simplified theories
you can then derive your hypotheses from
the theories the hypotheses are then
formulated in such a way that they can
be tested using collected data of course
theories have to be formulated first but
this is rather the task of qualitative
research qualitative research tries to
develop a theory on the basis of
collected data or observations this is
then an inductive procedure in reality
observed patterns are generalized
quantitative research can then be used
to test existing theories using
observations this is then a deductive
procedure the question then is thus the
theory agree with the observed results
short summary
the complex reality is explained with
the help of theories
you now want to test these theories with
the help of hypotheses
to do this you collect quantitative data
and analyze them
finally you can interpret the results
this knowledge can then be used to
improve the theories or create new ones
so all knowledge that is gained from
reality is collected in theories
after you have found the theories you
want to use you can start formulating
your hypotheses an example let's say
your topic is working conditions and
health
to start your search you create a list
of Search terms and conduct a literature
search for example you search for the
following terms chop stress workloads
Workplace Health and so on
at the end of your search you have a
list of quite a lot of studies that you
want to use for your thesis and you
write down the state of research
the theory you decide to use is the
model of effort reward imbalanced by
Johannes Seacrest what is the content of
the theory it is a theory about the
effects of stressful working conditions
on the mental health of employees
a mismatch between effort and rewards
leads to a higher stress level and to
poorer mental health of working people
from the theory you now derive the
general hypothesis the more job related
rewards like good pay appreciation and
so on employees receive the better the
mental health
you want to analyze this hypothesis as
good as possible so you turn it into two
hypotheses
the more appreciation employees receive
the better they rate their mental health
and the more dissatisfied employees are
with their pay the worse they rate their
Mental Health
now you just need to use the literature
to figure out the best way to measure
appreciation received mental health or
satisfaction with pay
then you create a questionnaire and use
a survey to ask your target audience you
can then analyze the collected data for
example with the help of a correlation
analysis more on the topic of hypotheses
and hypothesis testing in the following
video thanks for watching and goodbye